本日はこのようなとこ別の場所からピット
ボックスをお送りいたします
それでは早速ですが自己紹介を考えでお
願いしますはい私は研究者作家として活動
しています
研究者としては航空交通管理員はば空の
交通整備を取らようにスムーズに行うのか
といったシステム設計の研究をしています
その他にもですねスチーム+ d という
概念がありまして
科学サイエンスの赤門頭文字の s です
ねぴくの路地技術の p エンジニアリング
のいい
アーツの a
ますまあテックスの塩そしてデザイン b
ですねそれを融合した概念と国際連携に
ついて興味がありましてそのようなですに
教育活動ですとか講演活動平原勝つとまた
本の執筆も行なっています
高
サッカーと研究者の両立っていうのは
やっぱり大変ですかそうですねあの
時間のやりくりが大変っていうのと
やっぱりあの頭の使うところが違うという
かの切り替えが大変なのでそこが大変って
いうのとあとはのこの書庫なぁの研究者
ですね
理系の研究者の場合は存分の本数とかどれ
だけに押されたかでやキャリアが決まるん
ですけど一般車ですねあの一般の方にどれ
ほどわかりやすい本を買いたかって評価が
前で使ってない顔で青二鋼やちょっとあの
まああのキャリアにはならないところなん
ですけれども
でもやっぱりあの本を書くってのが好きな
のでやっ続けています
酵素の研究名で空の交通会議っていうのは
具体的にはどういったことをされるんです
か
今はその小人19の影響で一時的に航空
交通量も減ってるんですけれども
今後は長いスパンで見たときにここに順で
交通量がその小人19の前の2倍ぐらい
まで増えるって言う風に試算されています
あのそのようにもうますます混雑してくる
子はて空の交通ですね安全に効率的に関係
の負荷を小さくしながら
整備していくっていうのが形になってい
ますであの星花ですね航空交通っていうの
をあの
支えるインフラ基盤のシステムっていうの
がですね
1950年代60年団に基盤がつくられた
ものをどんどんアップデートしながらです
ねまあそうですせるなんですよ作っていて
もちろん今までの間に様々な技術革新が
あったわけで
例えばあの
今だとパイロットさんと管制官の方があの
航空機をぶつからないようにですね管制官
の人があのパイロットさんに進路を支持し
たいとか速度を指示したりとかですねやっ
てあげてそれを超えであったんですよね
電話かけるみたいな形でやっているんです
けれども
デジタル通信ですねあのもっとレジたの
情報を送受信できるようになったりとか
あとはの衛星を使えるようになったりとか
です
あとはーの今管制官の人はパイロットさ
んっていうのは飛行機の中國一の中から
周りの交通情報というのが目で見ることが
難しいので
地上で管制官の方がレーダーに映るが航空
交通っていうのを監視し布がぶつからない
ようにあのやってあげてるわけですけれど
も将来的にはあの航空機がですね自分の
持ってる情報ソーラーで放送できるような
それを育て飛んでる航空機が受信すると
管制官さんが持っている情報空手にも
見えるようになるのです
そういうふうなことをすると大空気がです
ねあの管制官の指示が無くても自立的に
飛行できるようになってくるとか様々な
技術革新があります今日はい今話して
いただいたところと少し被ってしまうかも
しれないんですけれどもこう未来の交通
管理というのはお空の交通管理って具体的
にはどうゆう
形相になってくるんでしょうか他にも様々
な機体っていうのが飛ぶようになってきて
ドローンですねあ警句を飛ぶような
ドローンがたくさん東大とかですね曽田
飛ぶ車って言われますけども都市交通
システムがならしくなったりとか
であとはですねあーもっと高いところこの
上の方の清掃ペンですねの高い所宇宙に
より近いところを飛ぶような超音速機とか
ソーラープレーンとかも曲んじゃない
かっていう風に呼ばれていますまあそう
ですね
この数年間でやっぱり宇宙開発ものすごい
勢いで成長もうしていると思うんです
けれども
動産のような航空の専門家から3で宇宙
開発というのはどういう存在なんでしょう
かそうですね宇宙っていうのをまずに人類
の活動のフロンティアだなっていうふうに
思っていましてみなさんのそうだと思うん
ですけどの火星の移住とか月面基地とか
そういうふうなあのー構想を聞くとですね
私もすごくワクワクしています
えあの
火星の探索とかありましたけれどもアドン
も使ってですね火星の探索をしたりとか
あとあの火星を飛ばす飛行機の研究って
いうのも住んでいたりして
宇宙と航空てねやっぱりの切っても
切り離せないなっていうところがあります
ね
あのまあ個人的にはですねやっぱりコード
4万フィートティアナこの航空機が
だいたい飛んでるような高度なんですね
その辺のしたあまり二年間貼られたくない
なっていう総合研究分野がそこのらへんな
のでありますねあとあのまあ研究者として
者だけじゃなくてもの個人としても
やっぱり購入幻の活動文化の恩恵を受けて
いたいというか受け科学技術もあのアート
もそうですけどもセフナの人間がたくさん
いてわちゃわちゃしながら生み出していく
ものの中で
楽しんでいたい鍋か受うけたいなという
気分があります
ありがとうございますそれでは御著書の中
でも触れられているスチーム+ d に
ついてはい少しご説明いただけますかはい
まずステムという概念がありましてステム
というのは
サイエンスの s ですね価格の s
テクノ6時技術の p エンジニアリング
高額のいい m ますマティクスのあの
数学の m ですねそれを合わせた概念で
いわゆる理系無学も全般を指しています
そこに a ですね
アーツの a を加えたものがスティーム
っていう風に呼ばれていましてダーツと
言いますとあのアートはですね日本語で
言うと美術とか芸術とかそういうふうな
ものに訳されるんですけれども
もっと広い意味がありまして例えば
ブドウだったらマーシャダーツ
稼いだた house all ディング
アーツっていうふうにですねもっと大きい
ものを指しています
ステムという理系の学問が資源詩前回の
演技をもとに分析してですね地縫い農繁
生かそうっていうのは曇ったとしたら
ガートっていうのは自然界にはないけれど
も人間が社会の中でですね工夫をして
作り出した学問全般いわゆる文系の額も
前半たと思うていますたとえば経済とか
邦楽とか政治というものもアートに含ま
れる
scheme 級のその理系文系問わず
そういうふうなものですねを合わせて
文洋横断的に10号地を使ってですね
新しい価値を見出していこうっていう考え
だと思っていますそこにデザインですね
設計の d っていうのが入ると目的を
持って目的に向かって新しい価値をつくっ
ていこう
長い人が
それでは私たちがその still + d
を学ぶことによってどのような未来が開け
ていけると考えていますかはい
様々なバッグブランド理系文系問わず
いうものを持つ人たちが一緒に共通の未来
ですねどういう3階がいいのかっていうの
を一緒に設計する理想を設計して
ソノリティ理想にが目指してですね一緒に
あの働いていくということで新しいタイプ
のですねこれまでの価値観ではそこができ
なかったような社会問題っていうのを解決
できていくと思いますは私たちのこれかな
未来っていうのはあの今までの想像でき
ないようなことというのが起こっている
変化に富んだものになると思っています
それはですね例えば日本でも少子高齢化と
か住んでいたりしてあのこれから日本だけ
じゃなくて先進国でももしかしたら世界で
も人口っていうのはヘ底部かもしれない
っていうの時代になっていきますあとあの
ものと人っていうものがインターネットを
通してですね結びつくようなデジタル変革
というもこれから進んでいく
そういうふうなあの変化していく社会の中
でステムの恩恵をどういう風にみんなで
享受するのか
その風とか規制づくりも併せて考えていか
ないといけない社会システムを作らないと
いけないっていうのがあります
てあの起こした問題っていうのは日本だけ
の問題じゃなくて世界規模で対応しないと
いけないっていう問題も
ています例えばの黒煙が示して sdg ず
今の話題になってますけれども
例えばの気候変動にどうやって取り組んで
いこう
いうのとか
持続可能な産業と回ずつの基盤っていうの
御紋みんなでどういうふうに作っていくの
か
水風な問題というのは日本の枠の中じゃ
なくって世界規模の国際社会の中で私たち
が取り組んでいく形になると思っています
じゃないん
それではこんなまでの伊藤さんのように
世界を舞台にして活躍したいと考えている
学生に対して何か一言お願いできますか
はい
古風なあの子119の最中にあって
いろんなことを我慢しないといけないって
いうことが若い人にあったんじゃないかな
と思います例えばの海がよくを行きたかっ
た海外留学行きたかったっていうのは
ちょっと諦めないといけなかったとかその
中であのーきれいにつけたらテレビはい
ないのバッハペアのアジア人の差別がどう
こうっていう風なアジェヘイトのあの問題
もニュースで流れてたりなんかしてその
自分たちの気持ちを口池させてしまうよう
なニュースとかそういう話題があったと
思うんです
私はですねあのヨーロッパであの
プロジェクトに入ったりしたときにアジア
人だがあって日本人だからっていうことで
プロジェクトから外されたりとかですね
それのこともあったであの者別てを多分
なくならないと思いますけれども
する中でですね理想に向かってです諦めず
に本当していくと本当の友人が出来て仲間
ができてぜひ方ジュっていうのと支え合っ
てですね今もいい仲間なんですけども私は
今ここで皆さんにお話できる立場になって
いるわけですよなのでするノアの
ネガティブな速ね差別とか何かあの
いや張らせるか嫉妬とか何かそういうふう
なものっていうのもたくさんあるけれども
全然も何も想像しないものですよねなので
そういう風なものは耳を受けるんじゃなく
て
新しい自分の未来ですね
向かって理想を持ってですね突き進んで
いって欲しいと思いますあのこれからの
未来っていうのがこんなに変化に危険な
もの新しい価値観で挑まないといけない
けど問題になっていますs のベアの様々
なバックグランドの人たちと折り返しあう
ひょー様を見つけてほしいと思います
ですねあの国籍とか飲酒と母姉区間問わず
みんなでもいいチームをつくってほしいと
思います変化を受け入れてその人たちと
一緒にですねあの挑戦して時には失敗する
かもしれないけれどそれより変えてですね
一緒にアニメを作っていくようなグループ
を言ってほしいと思う
母の活動を応援しています
はいっ
素晴らしいメッセージありがとうござい
ました